bisher entferntes des wasserstoffs
signal aufgespürt wasserstoff massen in
einer sehr weit entfernten galaxie und
mit ihr geschieht gerade etwas
spektakuläres jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction forscher aus den usa
haben im zuge des kosmos highlight extra
galactic server mit dem very large area
telescope kurz vl spuren von wasserstoff
in einer fünf milliarden lichtjahre
entfernten galaxie aufgesprüht die tat
dies ist das erste mal dass wir atomarer
wasserstoff in einer galaxie so weit weg
von der erde direkt messen konnten sagte
seminar fernandez von der rutgers
university in new jersey der bisher am
weitesten entfernte wasserstoff
emissions- und die gerade mal für eine
entfernung von drei milliarden löchern
in der fünf milliarden lichtjahre
entfernten galaxie achtung komplizierter
name kosmos es selber konnten die
wissenschaftler aber nicht nur ein
bisschen atom an wasserstoff finden
sondern sehr sehr viel davon und dazu
noch molekularen wasserstoff im laufe
des videos nennen wir die galaxie
übrigens einfach nur kosmos ich glaube
dass es etwas einfacher und wie viel
wasserstoff wurde da jetzt gefunden
es sollen jeweils rund 30 milliarden
sonnenmassen in der galaxie kosmos von
beiden wasserstoff arten entdeckt worden
seien also molekularen und atomen aber
was ist der unterschied also was ist
molekularer und was ist atomarer
wasserstoff und vor allem was ist so
besonders daran atomarer wasserstoff ist
ein einzelnes wasserstoffatom h1 ein
relativ freies radikal und kommt eher
selten vor molekularer wasserstoff
besteht aus mehreren wasserstoff atomen
die sich leicht durch elektrolyse zu
diesem stabilen h2 zusammenfinden jetzt
kommen wir zur besonderheit molekularer
wasserstoff kann mit viel energie
aufgespalten und zu atomarem wasserstoff
umgewandelt werden um ein einziges
wasserstoff molekül aufzuspalten braucht
man rund 4 elektronenvolt
problematisch bei der umwandlung ist die
instabilität der atomaren
wasserstoffteilchen sind
reaktionspartner in der nähe reagiert
atomarer wasserstoff rasch und sehr
gewaltig
mit diesen das heißt so viel wie
atomarer wasserstoff bleibt nicht
besonders lange atomarer wasserstoff im
weltall dagegen besonders in der nähe
von galaxien kann atomarer wasserstoff
viel länger in dieser form überdauern
die strahlungsenergie der jetzt
entdeckten galaxie schafft es so viel
energie aufzubringen um milliarden
atomare wasserstoffteilchen isoliert zu
lassen und das sind jetzt nur auf den
atomaren wasserstoff bezogen rund 120
milliarden elektronenvolt ziemlich viel
könnte man sagen dank der gewaltigen
energie die diese galaxie aufbringen
konnte die überhaupt erst entdeckt
werden zitat diese signale begannen ihre
reise noch bevor unser planet existierte
nach 5 milliarden jahren der reise durch
das all sind sie nun in unseren
teleskopen gelandet und erlauben es uns
diese galaxie zum ersten mal zu sehen
beschreibt fernandez faszinierte
entdeckung neben der energie ist die
unterschiedliche wasserstoff dichte in
bzw an den äußeren rändern der galaxie
kosmos auffällig seitens der forscher
heißt es dazu zitat während die galaxie
optisch ungestört aussieht spricht die
asymmetrische verteilung des neutralen
wasserstoffs dafür dass es eine
interaktion mit einem möglichen
begleiter gibt zitat ende kosmos könne
sich also bald mit einer anderen ähnlich
außergewöhnlichen galaxie vermischen das
ist spektakulär
um kostenlos überhaupt zu entdecken
beobachteten die forscher und 178
stunden das weltall
da man jetzt ein hinweis auf eine zweite
galaxie gefunden hat bleibt den experten
eine solch lange suche voraussichtlich
erspart um die zweite galaxie zu finden
die älteste bekannte galaxie ist neben
bayern wären ungefähr 13 4 milliarden
lichtjahre von unserer erde entfernte
galaxie bnz 11 entstand dabei
tatsächlich nicht nur vor unserem
planeten sondern zu einem zeitpunkt
nehmen das ganze universum gerade mal
drei prozent seines jetzigen alters
erreicht hatte
da war der urknall gerade mal 400
millionen jahre her
wer mehr dazu erfahren will kann gerne
mal hier oben auf das sie klicken dann
kommt er zu einem video dazu und wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich über einen einen daumen
nach oben
und natürlich wenn er ein kostenloses
abo da
lasst schreibt in die kommentare ob ihr
euch einen job im bereich gastronomie
vorstellen könnt ich finde es
unglaublich spannend 178 stunden wird
man da hoffentlich nicht immer ins rohr
gucken müssen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran